foreign
Jared is in Altoona Pennsylvania hi
Jared welcome to the Ramsay show
hey Dave and Christina I hope you guys
are having a good day today we are how
can we help
um yes so my question kind of in a whole
package deal today is
um my grandparents had their retirement
funds in a annuity that matured after 10
years right and
um about around last year I looked into
what the retirement plan was and it
looked like that their retirement was
basically getting zero interest per year
on that annuity but they were still
still taking out
um their their fees and their expenses
that the service that they had it in and
so I decided that I was going to manage
their funds for them and I decided to
pull that retirement out and roll it
over into a traditional IRA but doing
that it was a five percent penalty
because it was only five years into the
annuity and it was supposed oh you made
that up in one year that was brilliant
yes yeah if they were making zero and
you moved them into mutual funds making
10 or 12 they made 10 or 12 the first
year they lost five so they only netted
seven after that they make 10 or 12. so
absolutely I would have done that
the only thing is it was around last
year and now the market crash oh this
Market didn't crash the market went down
and it hadn't come back up but I mean
overall over the scope of their lives
unless they die this year this is a
brilliant move
but no I mean you you know the market
can come up and down but the average of
the market is has been 11.8 percent
since it started
mm-hmm and so let you know let's say you
cost them five and you made them eleven
then you made them a net of six
now this year you may or may not do that
um probably not in 2022 but 2023 you'll
be fine 24 there you know you're gonna
be just fine I mean some years you could
make 17 right I mean it's it's an
average
yeah I guess I was just nervous because
you know I transferred it all over they
they dropped I mean there's probably a
hundred K in it and then you know five
five grand off the top just came off of
that well and then they lost another
point and then they lost another 12 or
13. yeah yeah but but it's not you know
you didn't lose it until you cash it in
right no one gets hurt on a roller
coaster except those that jump off
during the ride
yeah you did the right thing Jared okay
that's what exactly what I would have
done
all right perfect that's all I want to
hear okay thank you
yeah that's hard yeah thank you so the
important thing to remember it folks is
this you cannot take a single snapshot
when the Market's down and use that to
make your judgments about your long-term
Investments that's a moment in time you
can't take a single snapshot when the
Market's way up
and go well I made 23 on my money last
year which I've had years I made more
than that you know well but that's not
the norm I mean you can't count on 23 no
but you can count on the averages well
and Jared I didn't ask his age but he
sounds young and if he's gen Z
Millennial this may be his first time
seeing the market go down significantly
so it is kind of scary if you've you
know gone through the season with covid
where it's been lots of highs and a lot
of people have been winning in the
market and then all of a sudden it goes
down it's easy to go oh my gosh I've
never seen this before but somebody like
Dave you've talked about how you've seen
the roller coaster throughout the years
somebody are you saying I'm old
but I know like Dave yeah but I mean
seriously that's it pan back from the
moment
and get not only a little bit of the
future in your peripheral vision but a
whole bunch of the past in your
peripheral vision and you see the trend
across something more than one month or
one year
because if you take a one month or one
year Trend in any investment and use
that to make your decisions you're going
to make a bad decision now I wonder too
if some of that anxiety he was feeling
was the fact that it's his grandparents
you know money and they're they're
probably needing that money right now
what would you say to that concern of
you know if it was Jared's money
specifically it'd be a lot easier to go
okay I'm not worried about it I'm not
going to retire for four years here's
the thing if you left it where it was it
was sucking
for sure it was gonna go it was gonna
you know it's costing money every year
sitting where it is he did the right
thing his anxiety is is that he just
wanted to make sure
he did the right thing for sure but for
retirees right now who are feeling
really nervous about the market what
would you say to them you don't need the
money
um when you retire with a million
dollars you don't cash a million dollars
out and set it at the kitchen table you
leave the million dollars in the
investment you live off the income and
so if this year you didn't the
investment didn't go up and so by taking
some month okay let's take let's do this
let's take the hundred thousand okay uh
Market's down 15 all right and you were
you want to live on ten percent of your
Investments so if you had a hundred
thousand dollars you want to live on ten
thousand dollars okay so you pull out
ten thousand dollars you got 90 and it
loses fifteen percent so you're done 25
percent
okay now
the next year it comes up
10 15 percent
comes right back up and you still pull
off ten thousand dollars
if you keep doing that math every year
up and down up and down up and down and
it averages 10 or 11 percent and you're
pulling off ten percent you will get to
even you'll get back to the hundred and
the hundred will just sit there over
time some Years it'll be 110 some Years
it'll be 90.
and it'll be back and forth right but
you're pulling off 10 the whole time and
it's just gonna it's gonna vacillate
back and forth so you're going to be
just fine and so that that's the thing
it goes down but it's not down
permanently so it'll keep coming up and
they can live off the income so the
point is you never in any of this case
took out the hundred
all you took out was the amount you need
to live on
and then it went down a little and then
it comes back it has it needs to come
back the amount you took out plus how
much it lost before you're back to your
hundred and it will over time it will
over time I mean and if it didn't it'll
be the first time in history